this is a production of Cornell
University okay well this is a morois
titanum this is the Titan arum or the
corpse flower um it gets the name Titan
arum from Sir Attenborough on BBC
special because he thought it was
inappropriate to talk about aoral phace
in front of family and children so he
dubbed at the Titan arum what you're
looking at is the largest unbranched
inflorescence uh in the Botanical world
and by inflorescence we mean a stem that
bears uh more than one flower so uh this
is actually uh a a structure that's
called the spai and the spaic uh this is
the Spath which is a highly modified
leaf that wraps around the uh which
will eventually eventually be revealed
when this is ready to be pollinated um
the spedix is a central stem that bears
uh numerous little flowers and in this
particular case the flowers that are
going to produce seeds are at the bottom
and the flowers that produce pollen are
up towards the top so when this flower
is ready to be pollinated this Spath
will unfurl looking like a dress of a
ballerina except upside down on the
inside it'll be brilliantly red to
Maroon uh to mimic the appearance of
Rotting Flesh because in addition to
producing that appearance of Rotting
Flesh it also releases a very foul smell
that attracts flies and also many
believe carrying eating beetles so that
red inner surface of the space is
supposed to mimic uh a carcass of some
kind of animal and the fragrance is
supposed to mimic Rotting Flesh to
attract flies and carrying
beetles uh to my nose this particular
species the the fragrance if we want to
dignify it with that word smells like
rotting uh fish uh a related plant the
cojac amorphofalis
cojac uh which is figured over there is
reported to smell like rotting mouse or
rat so each of the species actually has
its own fragrance and there's two at
least that are very pleasant in their
fragrance one smells like uh chopped
carrot and the other smells a little bit
like banana but we we are in front of
the corpse flower so that's the
reproductive aspect of the plant what is
hidden is the underground working part
from year to year year and that's the
corn so this is what the underground
part of the plant looks like uh
technically this is called a COR which
is a highly modified stem uh the INF
fluoresence the collection of flowers
with the Spath and spaic emerges from
the center of the Corn and in fact if
you look in here there's a very good
indication that this corn may be ready
to produce its own flour
so after the flower flowers open up and
are pollinated and produce seed uh the
entire infloresence Withers uh and uh
breaks apart after the fruits and seeds
are dispersed and this corn will send up
the vegetative parts of the plant the
plants that are photosynthetic uh these
are one or more leaves
so these are these are the babies of we
stinky that we collected uh 2 to 3 years
ago and thanks to the wonderful staff
here uh uh like Paul Cooper who have
kept these plants happy and growing well
uh we now have additional specimens and
this is what a leaf of the Titan arum
will look like this is uh not a stem
it's the base of a single leaf uh that
is then divided into three and they're
extremely decorative and extremely
beautiful plants I
think and then what will happen is
eventually these leaves will exhaust
themselves they'll become dormant and
the cor will rest for a while for uh an
unprescribed uh number of months uh and
then the cycle will be repeated over and
over again with some
luck I think it's it's U you know people
people like Paul Cooper who have done
such a brilliant job keeping these
plants happy that the same specimen is
actually flowering in less than 3 years
it's very unusual to have a corn uh
produce an inflorescence over such a
short time usually there's a resting
period of maybe five six and in some
cases as much as 11
years so after
pollination uh the space at outer skirt
of modified Leaf will wither and the
pollen producing flowers which are up
towards the top will also wither but
then what will happen is the individual
flowers the female plants uh each of
them will develop an individual fruit
and each of these now is the fruit of a
single flower uh the bright red is
believed to attract birds like horn
Bells which uh are
common in Indonesia sumantra and the
birds will uh it's believed uh disperse
these seeds they'll eat the outer fleshy
part of the of the fruit and the inner
part of the fruit is like a nut and
inside that nut is the actual seed and
that passes through the birds and that's
the way these plants get dispersed uh in
their native
environment
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu